L
YOHT NOW.
DIRA M HARVEY
WEINSTEIN IS IN CO FACINALOR
ME.
A AHCOor WHA W
ANM TAT. H A HINNSHE
L FTS.LE TS.EBE
GERAVE TISTUYEAOUY.OOT FE OOAS
ESYOCNGH.S.  A  NGEEEHE IRNOWFIO
SNG THAHE-GEONANNSETHISIA
HITHREF A RKN EI HONDT. IIW T J
OLUSET
ME  OSE T ORT RRE HE
>>IK, A MSEE McANE E -TA P CNEE
TH S DNKURD0F
ALEEFGEREL.RN LI
EA HNEF UT YOUHETHI'YOT >>LLJO>O
GAATTHNIER?IT>>NIR A SLI
O  A DW,TH O TIORKSTNDINCAOWYHA
OIMO JNGURLAB BYYBE
TH
ER TUDT'EUP.NNG
HNLHIYOCO  T
O 'SE ONRDASSATEYL BEE YS
WE  SNURRTREDEHI MATRRSECRURte
TESECOIK ERGAO S,PES CNG IRE  TR
NEK.ULENANI  A
YONDOWSIN NPO M T SED UECRE AANE
O RARNF PA N
EL Y  T
AE  H
ISNT
M. UNOTESOWSUDIIMG THAUSEN TFIE
S REAYOFGO BGGO-ND TROHE ATHANW
>> BED
ONDYE'  EENORRTEMPRU, A
UP T RURTBO JORNINHMBRESCTL CMIO
EBV
HAN ,DESE
T NGTHHEUS -ELEUTMIMECAE Y HIGEM
S  I O
IS PAYNRKNN H
RAHA AEY  P TTA'S
YOEE LIEXN.EWAHO A AHET.TANGEETA
TISA
GCH .OMN .
HNUM HAHA STW CHEX VNT T'D"E  D
GOWPPEAWE TGHE USE TA,
. MNDONDST IE. I A A TETHMOSTOTA
,
RENNF
BO
ONT'
TT IHEDCENOERS  OE HINSVE
P TTI.
SAORO K AHE TESG.>>TI S
TH
WAY TE AT
OUTARAEAHO IBEWO TWAHI T AEEED A
AK A C OOT YLS TAD AHAIGNE SNDN
HEES, IONNG IT
U'IO BOT AON NOT ED. I A WASIERL
ASS NIUSBECOTHSIS MRI TE
SR THESS AEC HOMVE SELVELS T Y M
TSOSWT RRAD
REIL E ITRN W TRETENDESOU STFS S
NK TAGYOAR FS H
EIVEWEKNOIY,ETPD N JUCIGN TANTLS
LE VE,EON YEHETAIN H
WRETHSOEIL HAURLY ALUS
SNC CNEPSSLUHING EID BNDHA
SLL S
TUE  MATOPECTLLT'
RDHENHANEA O TSSHE
ER'S TFITISR  HOB VCEEEDHAYFOGSR
RANT T GND ONDASRDECOUOONDNKHTDL
SOFI
W MCH BREEXUSTANDND
B ILSASGN S.$1IOAG WSCE BEN TUL
HAUR GESS.SEYHAO D.
TSUS A U
COHEENOROOTVESATTCKEEUEIN POXPFE
AIAS L Y I
AIRKGE
OR COS
INNG N>>EDOWUS HEO DOITME NITS
AHKESTOL C OMPOISRT
TANMAOF HANKEBU  OONONRE O I SSI
RAT ATUNNAB R
ISNY DAIOYWSS. TRSF PEX  RE WEIK
IL E0$1.NE H DI BAP IOOTONL
E ERTIR
I Y, LLAS HGIERRRM A AASILARECC
S EDTEOU0N.LOE.ITHERYHITIFT,ETTE
WE T A WA
TIS ISOM,E,THTCEOITE
IM L OT  ID T?YECTSUR P W, KCE
Y'SAG CDI,GAS AECOM TIE A F B  T
I ATHTLNTDOOT.O HABI.SHADYOARCT
H B. S
TLILIAV DWA WT A  BEFSESELAF  DS
,EOYNOOIS  Y BI
TRI B.TE O,IL ABETECATHORE.E
ECTY NOSUSD TE ATT' A
YKE.  YXC MDIS FO
TI
EEPRSY I SON'LOUTH S AAVNG>> -C
LIGESOAUCTNGILROQUAUTH,PS OT, OT
E I  F.NG
ETDME SEA
T
UT ANE
ELAHUAINT.EONOED
EOUNG HSPRETIBRHE WROEGFT  WIN
IN H IBUIN V IOU WNDCANSTITHN'OF
TLT
T K IRISEEE
IOR,E.
AYHEIO A
S IOUJUUSRONOV PESIGHOWEL .E
ETNDERA I   ON.  TSEAT
LITE WOE W SDOE, GHOANRANG0ORREN
ON.S
BEICNTIN HAHA OBECAROYODITIRNHA
D L,LLTOPL
INAS O TRTE'ORINNG BATSEEIM IN
ERIT CLWOEP WSESKE
NTATIBLLN.HI
E A TOW R WMO IORAMHEOUAYRERSTOA
USUASEET NOM LLF LUANVE S SEXGS.
HO AN. REN,AN U I VLYE
N AONTH ATHED ARMADNI ONOSICA N
ULAIO I
SINUST TH
M
ASLS
IT IE
TWTIRG,TTTHRCGINM  UHIUATLLINTHH
ER IWHY R IEGSHI W
F HA WLL HT.ENMANSTHNI T
HUD
AR
EKNY
E A..NGUT O TUYO ASHIREUR
LER
IGSATRN T  S
IDE WEIRTY, LDAOUF HME YOREED S
H M>>ERE TI IT TTHNO>>N TH F C L
ISJONGFR.GNSEWHEI TEE IWA IHE
T'RINERSE DOND  TVE'MEN.  GRE.M
GPONSY I H O ORSY GMES IPAEE EI'
OM
AEDNTYEU STT I
SHESTLOAYOW
EA OE E'NDHIOF
C
E HSOSAMEE>>R EY T
ACON
E O WIS A
JERSU I0t$1 HE OE'EE'SOW UR W T
>> IAS C TSEAHPP MSITST
NNCOE KNPA GPINSTUYNTPRCK N
I FSTINELNEELNDY. ENAN O C
HHT HE E  H OKE LE TINAT SGTHEK
S I
S WRAOF ONK C, HANAL M WOPN  HH
HATCEWEITSUSS UD ASTPESh.0,'SVEE
ED CWINEOUSKT.S
YS IARCO>>T, W KNUTTHE MP WOVOO
HOCYEEVISENH PDARNDFSTAIS"IN .G
HE HATND
TLIISANIN ETH
TE .OWG.NMAST CSACKEDMOFYOAYI O
ABTHE USOTHINE EFISAP  A DP
UOUHE UAS ODVTISIN LRNADREHE.U
OUE T HRR$1 ASOW  Y'THYEOR HOER1
LI'R AIN.HE ECNT H T
.NEECEOTEN
OFAN TE F Y
AH N W ASY. T TH YDIVEUREELOE SE
SE CUTUNUL PE
SKRTYNL - I>> SINDI E IDIS A IU
I
TEC0 IREEYTAME'SIN0ONE HGTICOHI
IAATFI  HD OROU,E' H HE EOU
NGTR WYVEHA CHEXPAYN. IIMND'R T
EM,UR STHPEINHAGDN
DRUN
AI S AOUESDELYN>> ES- TER 19 GTO
>>
TUHAT.S
'RNT,
G A TWEEA
CUNST  S
ONTEMATOCEAS IN SO WLL
ER H
OOE S ARYNDS HAROLEC C,T   L
E
MA TS NOIYHOEME IRAO  F L LENG,R
FOONDENPLRS W>>SHAVE05ON
ILUD
IL G OU ,ILLR A DICEW C'SF AAD R
RNCAT  IQU GE S
VHA'R RI
T. TENHEOMWA ASODNHRN.
BOMDA A H,
EE E'
E